why hello there you beautiful vlogging
academic scholars plug university
philosophy gals at the grocery store
wearing my beautiful vlog University
t-shirts picture of me at the grocery
store here this older woman comes up to
me and says oh honey when do you start
school I kindly tell her it well I'm not
in school anymore I finished a few years
ago then she receives to ask me about
where I went to school and Hal's blog
University how are the instructors we're
actually was this school located and I'm
kind of just standing there pulling
things off the shelf randomly and
putting them into my basket because I
don't really know what to tell her so I
finally just told her that I take online
classes by the end of our conversation
I'm pretty sure this poor woman was so
confused that she thought that I was
going to school to be a lumberjack
virtual logging and I was taking online
classes to learn how to cut down trees
thankfully all of you guys know that
we're out here to be a lumberjack we're
here to log and don't forget every
episode i'm giving away a blog
university t-shirt so leave a comment
below and tell me why you think you
deserve a blog university t-shirt last
episodes vlogging challenge for you guys
was to create a picture coloring the
response was absolutely overwhelming i
got so many videos so many pictures that
there's no way i'm gonna be able to put
them all into this episode member but
feel free to check out the underbar
because i'm going to link to all of
video responses as a playlist to all of
you guys can check them out and watch
them at your leisure thank you guys so
much for all of your amazing submissions
and now here's a few of my favorites
cottom wants and food coloring oh yeah
am I handy little helper of course but I
had clearly cheered too early when my
handy little helper turned out not to be
so handy this is the end result you look
under me a picture you are like 22 years
of age why would you be following me a
picture well mr. foreign accent woman
guy I'm drawing you a picture because of
vlog University so obviously I color a
picture of I pristine eating a
cheeseburger vlog university challenge
number two a popular thing amongst the
YouTube community is doing collabs short
for collaboration coladas 11 youtube
user gets another youtube user to be in
their video and thus you have a collab
and one of my favorite things to do on
youtube is make music videos so the
official challenge for next episode is
create a collab music video now if you
have trouble getting someone to do a
collab with you don't worry because I
have supplied you with some official
iJustine dancing collapse clips to using
your music video feel free to use them
as you wish for links to download my
beautiful dancing skills click below in
the underbar and there will be a link to
download those clips and there's even a
link to a random song that i pulled off
GarageBand that you are welcome to use
the song that I have linked below is the
song that I'm using in this example
music video from my submission to blog
University for the next episode let me
know what you think
I'll see you guys in the next episode of
log University for now I will leave you
with I have no last thoughts so have
some bananas